season two of the mandalorian was an
easter egg field extravaganza
one that had many star wars fans leaping
for joy from the return of boba fett to
the live-action debut of clone wars
favourites such as bokotan
and ahsoka tano the second season of the
mandalorian somehow cleared the high
bar set by the first but if you ask many
fans about the biggest surprise moment
the second season had to offer
they will probably mention a certain
cloaked jedi who makes an appearance in
the finale
in chapter 16 the rescue the mandalorian
and his allies have pitted against the
legion of dark troopers
and or hope looks lost until a young
luke skywalker arrives on the scene
brings down the evil droids and takes
grogu off for some special jedi training
it was easily the series biggest moment
thus far with skywalker's youthful
appearance coming down to some unique
technology and a little collaboration
with mark hamill
the star wars legend who is also a
self-professed fan of the series
it's very much in the spirit of what
george wanted uh originally
and uh i just thought it was
superb still although many fans loved
this moment others were less impressed
mostly by the execution of skywalker's
dating process
either way you're about to learn more
about the technology that went into this
cameo moment
thanks to an upcoming disney plus
special centered around it
mandalorian fans may have already tuned
into the documentary series disney
gallery the mandalorian
which offers a behind the scenes look at
individual episodes of the show
and provides crucial information about
how each individual story
and the series as a whole came to life
now that season 2 has run its course
most fans assume that the mandalorians
disney gallery series was unlikely to
return until the main show's third
season
those same people might be surprised to
learn that the house of mouse is
bringing back its popular
behind-the-scenes star q series
well ahead of schedule with a fresh
episode set to hit disney plus in august
disney plus will premiere the special
episode of disney gallery on august 25th
2021 which focuses on the return of luke
skywalker and the mandalorian season 2
finale
among other things the episode will
reveal more about the type of technology
used to resurrect luke in his classic
return of the jedi look
as well as examine the collaborative
process with mark hamill that proved
essential to making luke's appearance as
realistic as possible
so if you were one of the many star wars
fans who got a little teary eyed at the
return of everyone's favorite jedi
master then this new episode of disney
gallery will be right up your alley
but what can we actually expect to learn
from it well aside from knowing that
actor max lloyd jones was responsible
for the bodywork of young luke
there's precious little anyone does know
about the technical and collaborative
work that went into luke's return
it's possible to make a reasonable guess
how it all works considering similar
technology has been used in previous
star wars movies
and elsewhere in hollywood but nothing
is certain here
outside of the production nobody's even
sure how much involvement hamill even
had in the process
but while many fans will be thrilled to
get some answers to those questions
others might be less than thrilled to
return to the mandalorian season 2
finale
indeed while the moment of luke's
triumph from return garnered much praise
from many
some would have preferred that disney
recast a role instead of using the aging
technology
online star wars fans even had a
consensus candidate to fill young
skywalker's jedi boots
mcu mainstay sebastian stan twitter user
at djson81
summed up the most emphatic faction of
the fandom swords
after the mandalorian season 2 finale
aired tweeting
jesus christ just use sebastian stan for
luke
rather than this janky ps3 cutscene
looking version we got
of course it'll be interesting to hear
whether anybody ever considered
recasting luke for his special
appearance in the mandalorian
or whether it was the aging tech all the
way for john favreau and company
whether they did or not though we're
bound to know for certain when the
newest episode of disney gallery hits
disney plus
this august check out one of our newest
videos right here plus
even more looper videos about the
mandalorian are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one